alors maintenant enrico on va remonter
le temps en étant 63 il ya quarante ans
nous sommes au début de votre carrière
et je vous reçois sur l'horaire tf
interview flash mais enrico le décalage
64 ans je viens d'avoir 60 ans il ya 40
ans enrico à un an 63 ans né en 63 fils
et j'ai recommencé est mon corps je sais
plus que 24 24 ans voilà 29 roman qui
fait quand je suis pas là enrico vous
avez quel âge 24 ans bon alors que votre
carrière commence à très bien marché
mais est ce que vous pensez que les
durer comme ça avec cette taxe en pieds
noirs l'accent pieds noirs sur mes durer
comme ça non je croyais pas vous faites
des efforts pour le perdre cet accent
enrico à je prends des cours ah ouais je
prends des cours pour le perdre et nous
penser que dans quarante ans vous
l'aurais perdu mais j'ai déjà un peu
perdu six jeux alors mon pote ça va être
alors il faut maintenant ça commence à
marcher pour vous est-ce que vous allez
essayer la guitare électrique
ah mais j'ai déjà essayé la guitare
électrique mon fils il m'a fait jouer de
la guitare électrique mais c'est un
régal jamais je n'y jouerai de la
guitare électrique jamais jamais
d'après-vous enrico d'ici quelques
années
qu'est-ce qui va succéder au vieillit je
pense je pense que ça va être les
beatles un pense que ça va passer tout
dit elle ça va marcher
ah oui les beatles moi j'ai écouté leur
premier disque là vraiment
extraordinaire radio inséparables et
j'ai même appris que sylvie vartan
allait passer avec les beatles à
l'olympia avec trenet l'argent de la
chance le ps et moins les anglo saxons
et n'apprécie pas trop aidé géniale idée
vous l'appréciez aouij j'apprécie
beaucoup
je suis passé au moulin rouge n'y a pas
très longtemps
ouais mais il ya eu l'année dernière 70
ans 62 e et dernière je suis passé avec
johnny avec johnny juste après lui
j'espère que je serai là même carrière
que lui j'espère vous pensez que vous
sera pendant 40 ans propos pour dieu
veut si dieu on sait jamais on sait
jamais vous pensez pas qu'à l'idée avec
tous ces changements de style comme ça
une fois et les rockers une fois il
chante des chansons californienne vous
pensez pas que sa carrière va s'arrêter
il ya ici une belle bête de scène c'est
incroyable l'énergie qu'ils dégagent
il est capable de tout faire beaucoup
beaucoup de choses en plus de cela j'ai
remarqué parce que j'ai quand même une
oreille bien avertis voilà il a une voix
sensationnaliste touchante un leoni peut
tout chanter cloclo ça va durer
concluons alors procos et cloclo ses
genoux souhaite une très longue vie
alors que la france entière vous a
découvert dans cinq colonnes à la une
vous êtes devenu vraiment une star en
une soirée grâce à la télévision
est ce que vous croyez que dans le 40
ans vous fêterez vos quarante ans de
carrière à la télé c'est pas moi j'ai
fait un rêve prémonitoire d'aller me
voyez avec un homme en noir
ah ouais un homme en noir qui est tout
le temps habillés en noir un type qui
est la même tu vas voir la même voie que
vous est ce que vous croyez dans 40 ans
michel drucker sera toujours là drucker
il est calé en sport il nous fait des
bourdes europe des beaux reportages je
sais pas l'autre jour j'ai dîné avec lui
parce qu on est très copain on va voir
les matchs de foot ensemble et ils
rêvent de faire des variétés un bon il
rêve c'est d'animer des émissions de
variétés tout ça je le vois bien vous la
voyez comment l'algérie dans 40 ans
quelle question
c'est difficile déjà je digère à peine
le départ
ouais ben moi je souhaite que tout le
monde vive bien quoi 1 dont 40 ans et
que nous qui avons été déplacées
il n'y a pas si longtemps ben qu'on
arrive à se recycler qu'on arrive à bien
s'intégrer qu'on a vu il va bien se
faire aimer chez nous en france
ouais et que et bien que l'algérie aussi
soit heureuse et si elle a choisi
l'indépendance et ben ouais quelque
chose
moins de chance est ce que vous préférez
vous intégrez comme il faut en france où
retourner en algérie
moi j'aime en tout cas je me rappelle de
ce que m'a dit mon beau père avant sa
mort un jour avant sa mort il était venu
en france il avait fait un voyage et
puis il ne devait pas revenir parce
qu'il y avait beaucoup de rumeurs il des
complots qui sont 10es contre lui il me
dit je préfère mourir en algérie que de
vivre en france
une dernière question avant le choc et
enrico est ce que vous pensez qu'un jour
la france gagnera la coupe du monde de
football moi je suis comme la sncf 1
c'est possible
4 merci d'avoir été avec nous
m